Speaker 1: Let's go to it's either Ali or
Ali from Finland. Welcome to the program.
Ali. Ali.
Speaker 3: So. So who do you want to win
in 2024? And who do you think will win in 2024?
Speaker 1: You're talking about the
presidential race.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: It depends who runs.
I don't know who. I don't know
who's who the candidates are going to be at.
Speaker 3: Or do you want to be the president?
Speaker 1: Well, I there's people I think would
be good presidents that I don't even know if
they're thinking of running. I think Jamie Raskin
would be a great president. And I've mentioned to
that to him when I had him on the show, I think
Pete booted judge would be a great president.
Jon Ossoff probably lacks the experience
so far, but Jon Ossoff is interesting.
Stacey Abrams is brilliant. And, you know, I
think would be a very interesting president.
But, you know, a lot of this stuff is pie in
the sky. It's like, would George Clooney make
a good mayor of L.A.? I mean, maybe. But I don't
know that he has any interest in running. I it's
hard because I'm maybe too pragmatic where let's
let's see who runs, you know? Honestly, I think
Gavin Newsom would be a good president. He's not
the most progressive, but he's striking the right
tone when it comes to dealing with Republicans.
I think there's lots of interesting people. I
just don't know if any of them are going to run.
Speaker 3: Right. Okay. So the second question,
what do you think are the greatest priority
goals for the country? And how would you
prioritize achieving those?
Speaker 1: Well, I mean,
that we need I need 10 hours, really. But
zooming out, I think the most important
issues for the country to deal with that
will trickle down and affect other issues,
include campaign campaign finance and how politics
is financed, how elections are run. Where I would
like to get off of the Electoral College system
and I would like to get off of first past the
post. And we've talked about do you do that
via the national popular vote in your state
com pageant? Each of these topics is hours of
discussion. I think dealing with climate change,
because if you're in a climate crisis,
you can't be an activist for any issue.
And then probably number four. Getting health care
to everyone. Because if you're sick and can't get
care, you're also limited in your ability to be
an activist, to work, to earn a living, etc..
So I would say those are the four top issues.
Speaker 3: Right. So. So do you think, like it's
better to campaign for the president or Congress.
Speaker 2: Or overall or.
Speaker 3: What's or what's the best way you're.
Speaker 1: Saying as a candidate or as a voter?
Speaker 3: I support a.
Speaker 1: Yes. Oh, I think you can do all of
the above. I mean, listen, you can phone bank for
multiple candidates. You can donate to multiple
candidates. I think that it's not about more or
less important. It's your your congressperson and
your senator. Deal with different things than your
mayor and city councilor and the president. So,
I mean, in an ideal world, people would
be involved in all of them, and not all
of those elections are at the same time either.
Speaker 3: Right. Okay. That was so my questions.
Speaker 1: All right. Ali from Finland,
how was Finland these days? Uh.
Speaker 3: Snowy. Snowy.
Speaker 1: So. Okay, did you. Do
you live in. Where do you live? Helsinki.
Speaker 3: I know Tampa.
Oh, I used to live in Helsinki.
Speaker 1: What's that like? Is it
a large city town?
Speaker 3:
Uh, it's the third largest, I think, based on.
Speaker 1: Population. What's the population?
Speaker 3: You're putting me
on the spot, I think. 300,000.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. Very interesting. And is
it a place where what? When does the sun set at
this time of year?
Speaker 3:
Oh, it's like 4:00.
Speaker 1: Oh. All right,
well, that's not that crazy.
Speaker 3: No. Show up by,
like, ten and go start out for 6 hours, maybe.
Speaker 1: Oh, the sun doesn't come up until ten.
Yeah. Oh, is that. Is that rough?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yes.
Speaker 1: Oh, interesting. Interesting. Wow. Wow,
wow. Yeah. I don't know that I would deal well
with that. Well, listen, I really appreciate
the call. It's been great hearing from you.
Speaker 3: Yeah, you too.
Speaker 1: All right. There we go,
folks. We heard from all over the world. We
went to Ireland, we went to Finland. We went.
Where else did we go? We went everywhere.
That's it for calls today. I will take
calls again and hope to speak to you soon.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.